tristar ya use da oh this is what we
will set out to do well thank you
everybody for coming along something's
in here something we can turn the good
news into a good life for you and your
family Britain can be better let's make
it happen yep exactly what a manifesto
is ok sorry guysI as you can probably
hear I've got a huge cold to worry I'm
afraid I've got limited time
net margins I'm we just were just
talking about you keeping your know
where mr. for us nice guy fakir he got
straight to the heart of the matter
action this is a career-defining country
defining election pins are in the year
five of passionate Prime Minister and I
really feel so passionate of anybody
getting Lively about it when I feel
bloody lively about it these six pledges
are now carved in stone taking my shoes
off Russell Brand's a joke right ed
Miliband hang out with Russell Brown
he's a joke I'm amor you've got a fone
labor am i tough enough I'll top it off
hell yes I'm talking it the real
audience are sitting at home you cannot
left that note hang on there's not
anything that Nigel Farage would leave
on for dinner
yeah you see I warned you at the
beginning I said they were all the same